this was not the eu welcome they were
after razor wire and riot gear
poland's answer to a growing
humanitarian crisis on its eastern flank
but who can be steely-faced when you're
looking at this
this sea of humanity huddled together
for warmth camped out on the tarmac
where belarus meets poland
pilarus gave us visa
we came here
i do it is
our way to go to europe how much did you
have to pay for the whole package to
come
2 000
do you feel that belarus
sold you a false hope
i don't know
we are waiting we don't know what will
happen
they've been out in the woods for days
weeks even they've learned how to manage
but it's only going to get colder
and there are the old here and the sick
the blank stares of children who need a
roof over their heads
and a few even who are desperate to get
home
i keep getting asked what is the eu
going to do as if those troops won't
answer enough the response that they're
planning for the sanctions on the
lukashenko regime is not really much
help to people here
and a lot of people have more faith in
the eu's goodwill than perhaps they
should the european union
just like working every day to solve our
problems to let us in they push the
polish government
to open the gates to let us in
the belarussian leader threatened to
flood the eu with migrants and that is
exactly what he is doing payback for
sanctions the cynical abuse of mostly
iraqi kurds who were hoping for a better
life
but there's nothing to feed the children
here either and after brutally
suppressing his own people alexander
lukashenko is now subjecting so many
more to mistreatment the pawns in his
power games with the west
diana magnus sky news on the belarus
polish border